back at home in Sacramento yes I'm back
in my home no it's not because I had to
go back home I'm visiting for a family
emergency but you know they just didn't
really prepare it for me to come nor do
they really wanted me to come back so
hey what is going on YouTube now for
those of you out there who have not seen
this video this one's a doozy now I'm
not sure if you guys know who Ronda
Rousey is but this [ __ ] is hilarious
Ronda Rousey is actually the current UFC
bantamweight champion which means she is
somebody who [ __ ] you up now what is bad
to wait you asked bad to wait is a
classification and where you would what
is where I'm with Beth Batman you home
is where Batman and I don't [ __ ] I don't
[ __ ] know
now in this clip you will see a man
tartar I've got to be honest I don't
think you have as much strength and can
compete with the man and then I thought
my ribs break I think get his ass handed
to him a kiss right here serve it on
flat now apparently after she judo
smashed his foot to the floor
he broke about four of his ribs but the
guy who actually smashed his ribs got
his balls smashed and his pride
destroyed you know he does this for a
living he's actually the host of the
show and he's supposed to make jokes and
throw jabs at her and said this time
you're not really laughing at this joke
listen straight up whether you are a
male or a female you do not go against
someone who is a trained fighter and you
can't go around and tell a trained
female fighter that you could beat her
just because you're a male you want to
die Abhijeet that woman snapped your
dick off like an angry chimpanzees
patronizing a fighter because of a
gender is not a way to start your day
you must be that type of dude that has a
lot of great ideas like sticking your
dick inside a blender don't know you
really want to make that joke and you
thought it would be funny so I'm really
trying to get inside your mind so you
were probably thinking she don't throw
me but it's not gonna be that hot but in
reality
let me ask you something do you know
what trained fighter means hmm a trained
fighter means you are dealing with
someone who woke up one day and said you
know what I'm gonna do for living get
punched in the face these [ __ ]
are right you know what most people give
you advice on how to pick a career they
tell you to use your head first
they don't mean literally I thought
naturally you supposed to avoid getting
hurt
well not me I'm a gentle so sometimes I
don't even play frisbee because that
should be like I mean I enjoy mixed
martial arts I'm just saying I think
there are other professions where you
can make money without getting hurt I
went out the conversation went down when
you told your parents you don't [ __ ] up
your face for a living honey what do you
want to do for a living I want to get my
balls back mom okay good luck with that
Ronda Rousey by the way she's not
something run-of-the-mill fighter she is
dominating her sport the last time I met
she had she wanted so fast you could fit
the whole fight on instagrams look I'm
gonna just put this out there Ronda I
don't know you and underneath all that
makeup I could tell you have the blood
of a thousand babies and all obviously I
personally don't know what somebody's
gender has to do with some one weapon
you ass makes me wonder would you have
said the same [ __ ] to a female tiger
well anything Lady Tiger you ain't go by
me cuz you at all Ronda Rousey is
actually the current UFC bat - you know
when most people tell you to pick ha ha
you [ __ ] up now before you brave my
parents don't come in right now